I carry two phones with me this small
one is only known by my family and very
very close friends and when it rings
I'll always answer it because it has to
do with something going on with my kids
or my family this phone this larger one
probably 10,000 people have this number
I'm a believer that this concept of
access in other words many managers
think well you know if I give my number
out to my employees they may call me and
the truth is you want to hear from them
you want to hear the bad news first what
I found is the more people I give this
number two the less it rings I tell them
simply look I want you to have this
access because I respect you and I want
you to know that you can come to me and
in that trust I find that most people
never use it this thing does not ring as
much as my family phone does but when it
rings it's a big deal